There a particular genetic snip that has predisposed me to oxalate issues
Also, I have ordered the oxalate scavenger and oxalate balancer with the scavenger B for when I am having a flare-up and the balancer be daily
Yes, that's typically how you use it
We do have patients that might typically make cancer patients, but I have some genetic patients that do both of them on a daily basis
They just have a few different things in them
But yes, there are genetic steps for oxalate issues
So I'd have to look at your genetics again. Now a person can have oxalate issues without having oxalate gene defects
so
Remember it's epigenetics that from genetics
however
most people that have oxalate issues have oxalate gene defects
so
but
But we could look at that again if you were to set up our own scientific look at that again